well as Americans gather for a third
covet era Thanksgiving to other viruses
of concern are also spreading flu and
RSV the flu is spreading fast and early
this year the CDC is reporting that
hospitalizations from the virus are the
highest they've been in November since
2009-2010 flu season and RSV is putting
record numbers of children in hospitals
CBS News chief medical correspondent Dr
John lepuc joins us now Dr John Lapu
good morning Happy Thanksgiving
Vlad so how can Americans this year
celebrate their Thanksgiving with family
and friends safely what's the advice
well we're already here so hopefully
they've already gotten vaccinated
against covet against flu there is no
vaccine yet for RSV and they've been as
careful as they can in the last one or
two weeks I think to me it makes sense
that during travel especially if you're
around people you know a lot of crowded
situations I know everybody is fed up
with mass but say you're boarding a
plane or you're getting off the plane
you know pop on the mask it's not so
hard to do and if you want to take it
off later that that's fine now now we
get to today so people wake up if you
wake up and you are not feeling well
please stay home all right you know the
gift that you want to give on
Thanksgiving is not a virus that's right
or infection
um and so that that's hard to do I know
it's a big plan but that's what you
should do now for everybody else uh now
you get into risk tolerance risk benefit
and people may want to test before they
get together and do you do it as soon
before you walk through the door as
possible now you know my father-in-law
is a hundred years old so when we would
get together with them with him uh and
his wife we would test right before to
make sure other people may feel you know
what I I just don't want to do that now
you walk into the room and it's crowded
here is where the big lesson what is the
big lesson we've talked about it so many
times about covet and how it's spread it
spread through the air so this virus and
other respiratory viruses RSV flu they
have the potential to float through the
air and Air souls and gradually
accumulate build up over time especially
if there's bad ventilation over there's
poor ventilation so what can you do once
you're in that situation
crack a window open the door outside
safer than inside if you've got a some
kind of the air filtration air purifier
then use that and then the last thing I
would say is
if throughout all that you're somebody
in that room and you're just feeling
uncomfortable Because You're vulnerable
okay don't be afraid don't be shamed
about putting on a mask I know there's a
lot of peer pressure no shame no shame
believe it you know a lot of our
attention's been focused on covid but
the flu as we're hearing is coming back
with a roar how do we get folks to get
vaccinated and what can they do to sort
of like prep on that game
yeah well it's come back you know we've
had a couple of Seasons where it's been
relatively low and now maybe people
aren't as immunized against it every
year that's sort of like a booster when
you when the tens of millions of people
get infected with with flu now they come
back there's a big spike of it and I
think the flu vaccine has been shown to
decrease infection and also decrease the
risk if you do get the flu even though
you were vaccinated that you're going to
be hospitalized why is it so high I
think it's high because we've had a
couple of years where it's been time out
you know so we we get this annual and
it's amazing how many people get
infected with the flu Millions every
year and even people who don't realize
it so they're getting like the
equivalent of a booster so their
immunity is built up year after year now
it's been a couple of years everybody's
been careful now it's cold and flu
season they're indoors they're not
they're not being as careful they're
taking off the mass and they get
infected mask up ventilate and keep your
distance there you go never mind that Dr
Le puke always great to see you great to
see Thanksgiving